cursed to roam the rivers and lakes for
eternity searching for her lost children
the tale of Leona is one that has been
terrifying those in Latin America and
Hispanic cultures for centuries she is
often depicted as a tall thin ghost
blessed of natural beauty and long dark
hair roughly translated layer una means
the weeping woman as she roams the
rivers and creeks weeping and wailing
searching for her children those who
come across her are set to be dragged
screaming into a watery grave the exact
origin of lair ona is unclear and there
are many versions about how she became
the weeping woman one of the more common
variations is that a young beautiful
woman named Maria full of life and love
married a wealthy man who showered her
with gifts and attention after Maria
gave him two sons things began to change
they began to drift apart and he
returned to his old ways having many
affairs and turn into alcohol to dull
his boredom he would often leave Maria
and his two sons alone for months at a
time and it appeared that he no longer
cared for Maria eventually he decided
that he would leave Maria for good and
he married a woman that he believed to
be of his social class he would only
return to visit his children and this
caused Maria to feel great resentment
towards her two sons
one evening Maria and her two children
took a stroll on the riverbank
she came across her husband with his new
wife as they rode by in a carriage after
seeing the two together
Maria's anger could no longer be
controlled she lashed out at her
children grabbing them and throwing them
into the river as their bodies floated
down the stream and began to disappear
only then she realized what she had just
done she attempted to run down the
riverbank and save her children but it
was too late
Maria was overcome by grief and she ran
through the streets wailing according to
the legend lion-o mourned her children
day and night she roamed the nearby
rivers in her white gown hoping that
eventually her children would come back
to her she refused to eat and sleep
until she grew so thin that she
resembled a skeleton eventually she
finally died on the banks of the river
where she lost her children it wasn't
long after that her Restless spirit
began to appear and could be seen
walking down the banks of the nearby
rivers in the darkness her weeping and
wailing could be heard at night and the
locals afraid of what they'd heard
stopped going out after dark according
to the legend if she came across a child
she would attempt to take that child and
drown them in the lake in the hope that
she would be given her children back in
return in some versions of the myth she
kills anyone who crosses her and in
others only children
the tale of lair ona was often told to
frighten children as a way of stopping
them sneaking out of the house at night
for you may be kidnapped by lair ona
I hope you guys enjoyed the video and
I'd like to hear from you in the
comments below have you heard of layer
on her before and if so what version of
the tale were you told as always I've
been your host mythology in fiction
explained
[Music]